tant sur la piste du suspect responsable
du virus informatique iloveyou il
pourrait s'agir d'un jeune homme
identifié aux philippines le pirate
serait taj est de 23 ans et aurait donc
réussi l'une des opérations les plus
destructrices de l'histoire commentaire
nabila taboury alors que le virus
iloveyou poursuit sa route destructrice
les enquêteurs eux seraient sur le point
d'arrêter l'auteur de cette
contamination informatique sans
précédent
il s'agirait d'un philippin de 23 ans
habitant manille la capitale
le jeune homme aurait piraté le système
informatique de cette entreprise d'accès
à internet
s'il devait être motivée par un accès
gratuit à internet qu'il ait eu des
intentions plus grave et fils de je ne
sais pas vraiment ce ne sont encore que
des spéculations
il n'était peut-être même pas conscients
de la gravité de son acte à ilo veyou
utilisent les messageries électroniques
et les carnets d'adressés des
ordinateurs pour se propager de façon
automatique
il a déjà contaminé des millions
d'ordinateurs aux états unis en europe
et en asie une société informatique
romaine a été la première à proposer une
parade au virus de jeunes informaticiens
ont réussi à maîtriser puis à détruire
iloveyou explorateurs pénètrent chaque
dossier de l'ordinateur pour chasser la
séquence déficiente
quand il l'a trouvé il supprime les
dossiers atteint ses algorithmes sont un
antidote contre iloveyou mais pas un
vaccin
ils sont capables de réparer les dégâts
d'une première attaque mais ne protège
pas d'un second assaut d'autant que
depuis mercredi
deux variantes du virus commence à
envahir les ordinateurs